bonjour Philippe Tabarro bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous accompagner pendant
cette première demi-heure élue des
Alpes-Maritimes membres du groupe les
républicains auteur d'un rapport sur les
zones affabées émissions dont on va
longuement parler dans quelques instants
mais d'abord dans l'actualité on l'a vu
ce sont ces assises des finances
publiques qui avaient lieu hier 10
milliards d'économistes annoncé le
gouvernement elles sont faites sur les
dépenses de santé les aides au logement
la fiscalité sur les carburants vous les
encourager ces économies
oui bien sûr on ne peut qu'encourager
ces économies mais ce qui est prête à
sourire je dirais que c'est ceux qui ont
creusé les déficits de notre pays record
d'Europe des déficits publics record
d'Europe des des prélèvements publics
records d'Europe de la dette voilà et ce
gouvernement fortement accentué
malheureusement ces tristes record et
aujourd'hui explique comment va faire
des économies oui la charge le poids de
la dette est trop lourd dans notre
budget mais il faut être
particulièrement vigilant pour que ces
économies ne se fassent pas comme bien
souvent sur le dos des autres et je
pense notamment sur les collectivités
territoriales
c'était la bonne méthode cette politique
de la chaise je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas c'est vrai que ce qui a été dénoncé
par les associations des lieux est vrai
c'est un jeu de de dupes c'est un double
discours les collectivités ont déjà fait
un certain nombre d'efforts conséquents
les baisses de dotation
ont beaucoup marqué les élus locaux donc
pour toutes ces la maison il semble que
ce serait bien que l'État s'applique à
lui-même ce qu'il souhaite voir faire
également aux collectivité je pense
notamment ce qui a été la cause du
boycott c'est l'annonce de du point de
la réévaluation du point du
fonctionnaire qui qui est une décision
de l'État mais qui financé par les
collectivités il y a de plus en plus de
décisions
ait changé dans la journée ce qui a
particulièrement hérité
on va parler des zones affaiblissement
puisque vous avez remis un rapport
là-dessus leur mise en œuvre suscite
beaucoup de tension et pourtant elles
seront obligatoires fin 2024 dans les
grandes agglomérations alors comment
sortir de l'impasse c'est la question à
laquelle vous avez cherché à répondre
avant de vous écouter on va voir ce que
contient votre rapport avec mathiasarès
[Musique]
bonjour Mathias bonjour Oriane bonjour
monsieur le sénateur bonjour et d'abord
Mathias on va faut pas comprendre ce que
sont ces zones affaiblies c'est ça c'est
un dispositif que connaît bien le
sénateur Tabaro ici présent pour avoir
longuement travaillé dessus à l'origine
ces zones affaiblissement sont créées en
2019 et pour 11 métropoles simplement
Paris Lyon Marseille Rouen Strasbourg et
d'autres objectifs interdire les
véhicules polluants des centres-villes
afin d'améliorer la qualité de l'air les
véhicules sont ainsi classés en cinq
catégories par ordre des missions de
particules polluantes appelées critères
en fonction de leur carburant de leur
date de mise en vente en 2021 deuxième
phase la loi climat et résilience là le
dispositif était tendu à 43 villes de
plus de 150 000 habitants et un store un
calendrier stricte des interdictions au
plus tard au 1er janvier 2025 il ne doit
plus être possible de circuler dans ces
villes qu'abordent un véhicule de
critères 1 ou 2 sous peine d'une amende
Oriane et Mathias c'est l'application
qui coince voilà de facto imposés
l'utilisation de véhicules dit propre
donc plus récent engendre un coup pour
bon nombre de ménages votre rapport le
souligne monsieur Tabaro c'est aussi ce
que pointe une consultation en ligne sur
le site du sauna du Sénat pardon mené
entre mi avril et mi-mai 2023 elle a
rassemblé 51 000 contributions parmi les
critiques envers le dispositif on
retrouve notamment le manque
d'alternative à la voiture individuelle
pour les habitants les plus éloignés des
métropoles concernées le coût d'un
véhicule neuf je le disais une mise en
application trop rapide des dispositifs
certains parlent même d'exclusion
sociale ou même d'injustice vous avez
d'ailleurs interrogé le ministre de la
transition écologique Christophe Béchu
sur le risque d'embrasement que cela
pourrait engendrer c'était mercredi
dernier lors des questions d'actualité
au Gouvernement voici sa réponse
c'est pas parce qu'un objectif est noble
que les moyens qui permettent de
l'atteindre ne doivent pas être regardés
de façon fine notre vision elle est
simple protéger la santé de nos
concitoyens faire en sorte d'avoir une
réforme qui soit concrète et qui
assouplisse le dispositif des feux en
préservant l'essentiel mais en évitant
les crispations qui pourraient générer
par une application aveugle alors cette
consultation en ligne a battu des
records de participation alors même s'il
faut prendre avec des pincettes ce qu'il
en ressort est-ce que c'était important
pour vous de signifier ce risque
d'embrasement au ministre et est-ce que
ça répond vous a satisfait écoutez sa
réponse on verra il nous a donné
rendez-vous au 10 juillet on attend avec
impatience les conclusions ce rapport je
dirais que il fait le point sur la
situation
pardon et le ministre peut s'en emparer
s'il le souhaite donc voilà il y a pas
de droit d'auteur sur ce rapport il doit
s'en emparer on a fait un certain nombre
de recommandations de 9 recommandations
qui pourrent les améliorations possibles
on remet pas encore le problème de santé
publique qui existe à travers la
pollution on a été très clair sur ce
sujet par contre il y a une
acceptabilité sociale qu'il faut
absolument accompagner et puis il y a
une transition qui est trop rapide on a
cité beaucoup les exemples étrangers et
les défenseurs des aides ça marche bien
à l'étranger pourquoi ça marche plutôt
bien l'étranger parce que cette
transition c'est faire une vingtaine
d'années et nous on essaie de le faire
en cinq ans c'est tout simple donc c'est
un problème de calendrier c'est un
problème entre autres de calendrier
c'est un problème de moyen d'aide mais
d'être qui soit plus ciblée ça doit pas
être des aides universel ça doit être
des aides vis-à-vis des personnes qui
les ménage modestes qui ont un reste à
financer qui est trop important pour
faire cette transition vers l'électrique
ou vers le
parc de d'occasion et puis c'est
également une offre de transport en
public de transport en commun qui est
vraiment insuffisante dans notre pays
par rapport à d'autres pays européens
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle un choc de
l'offre de transport pour qu'il y ait un
vrai report modal donc je pense que le
constat peut être partagé aujourd'hui il
dépasse les clivages politiques c'est
intéressant parce que il n'y a pas que
mon groupe qui a voté ce rapport au sein
de la commission et bien d'autres
groupes et puis on voit qu'il y a des
initiatives qui sont prises sur tous les
bords de l'échiquier politique
aujourd'hui je pense que ça doit être un
sujet transpartisant et puis on doit pas
se cacher la réalité il faut être lucide
est-ce qu'on est en capacité d'ici deux
trois ans de remplacer 13 millions
d'automobiles thermiques dans notre pays
probablement non il y a et c'est même
sûrement non il y a des objectifs qui
ont été fixés au niveau européen en 2035
pour la fin de ces véhicules mais il
faut pouvoir m'avancer
progressivement accompagner les
personnes et puis aussi que l'industrie
française notamment la production
automobile puisse monter en puissance et
baisser en prix on va revenir sur tout
ça dans le détail Mathias puisque dans
le rapport évidemment il y a des
alternatives c'est ça alors le Sénat
dans un premier temps tenté de repousser
la date d'application de ces effets au
moment de l'examen de la loi climat et
résilient c'était en 2021 leur repousser
leur caractère obligatoire de 2025 à
2030 ce qui laisserait par exemple le
temps de développer l'offre de transport
en commun comme vous le disiez ça a été
une tentative sans succès alors les
sénateurs et Monsieur tabaron en premier
lieu dans son rapport avance d'autres
pistes mieux aider les ménages les plus
modestes ceux qui habitent en dehors des
et des feux mais qui les empruntent et
qui n'ont pas forcément les moyens de
remplacer leur véhicule par de
l'électrique pourquoi pas même imaginer
vous le disiez une aide au diesel ou à
une essence plus récente et donc moins
polluantes mais ce n'est pas tout les
sénateurs veulent aussi agrandir le
cercle des réflexions aux autres de
pollution dans les villes que sont le
logement l'industrie ou l'agriculture
monsieur Tabarro comment est-ce qu'on
s'attaque à ces autres émetteurs mais on
a voulu faire ce constat et bien
préciser les choses on parle de de
pollution on parle de santé publique
donc de responsabilité de l'État sur ces
sujets premièrement d'où la question de
l'information et du contrôle ou l'État
doit monter en première ligne et puis il
faut faire la part des choses parce
qu'on entend un petit peu tout et
n'importe quoi il faut faire la
différence entre les oxydes d'azote les
noces qui tuent environ 7000 personnes
par an qui produisent un certain nombre
de de maladies
également et puis la question des
particules fines et autant sur les
oxydes d'azote c'est le trafic routier
qui est principal ma responsable à
hauteur de 54% des maladies qui sont
générées par cette pollution tant pour
les particules fines le transport
routier arrive
environ en troisième ou quatrième
position et il y a d'autres domaines
beaucoup plus émetteurs que le routier
c'est ce qu'on a rappelé que ce soit le
logement le chauffage à bois l'industrie
ou l'agriculture donc on a voulu
remettre quand même les choses en place
les ZFE si elles sont mises en place
dans notre pays au rythme qui est
souhaité ne vont pas régler les
problèmes de pollution en général et
encore moins de particules fines mais
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire alors du coup
est-ce que il faut changer la loi pour
décaler la date d'obligation de ses
élèves nous on a été très cohérent dans
ce rapport on a repris les
préconisations et les votes qu'on avait
eu lors de climat et résilience
malheureusement on avait perdu un
certain nombre de combat lors de la
commission mixte paritaire avec nos
collègues députés mais l'idée c'était
déjà de repousser ce calendrier parce
qu'il est intenable je vous ai parlé de
l'exemple des 13 millions de véhicules
on s'est rendu à Marseille et on s'est
rendu compte que par exemple dans un des
arrondissements les plus pauvres de
France le troisième arrondissement de
Marseille va être est en dépassement et
le sera dans deux ans donc en 2025 comme
vous l'avez très justement dit il faudra
à ce moment-là interdire les vignettes
critères 5 4 et 3 donc 52% des personnes
de l'arrondissement le plus pauvre de
France change leur véhicule ça n'a pas
de sens et on en vient à la principale
inquiétude c'est cette ségrégation
sociale oui des personnes nous ont envie
on nous a on nous a sorti des métropoles
parce que on ne peut pas se loger et
aujourd'hui on nous interdit de revenir
pour travailler ou même pour avoir nos
loisirs c'est 50% des personnes qui sont
concernées par les édefeux qui vivent en
dehors des adefe c'est une triple peine
on l'a appelé comme ça dans le rapport
hier il y a des députés de la France
insoumise qui ont demandé la suspension
de ces zones affaiblissement là où le
taux de transport en commun est un foie
une fois et demi supérieur au temps de
trajet en voiture vous suivez ça écoutez
j'ai pas vu en détail les propositions
de des
députés LFI se réjouis maintenant comme
je vous l'ai dit que ce sujet devienne
transpartisan on a eu des réflexions
très positives d'autres groupes au sein
de la commission je pense que ça dépasse
l'écrivage politique et puis il y a une
différence entre
le fait que peut-être les choses ont été
faites à l'envers on crée ces effets
alors que les alternatives à la voiture
sûrement d'être efficace
l'enquête qu'on a pu réaliser sur le
site du Sénat et vous l'avez très
justement dit on fait des murs de mots
c'est voilà dans du qualitatif des démos
qui reviennent dans la bouche des des
personnes qui participent dans des
questions ouvertes et ce qui revenait
particulièrement c'était charrue avant
les bœufs c'était voilà des termes comme
ça qui sont très concrets qui montrent
que ça a été elle fait de manière non
synchronisée moi j'ai voulu faire mon
rapport au tout autour de la
synchronisation oui on doit avoir des
objectifs de santé publique important
conséquent par contre on ne peut pas
mettre en place les interdictions alors
que les offres alternatives n'existent
pas soit sur les véhicules électriques
soit sur les transports en commun donc
il faut vraiment avoir ça en tête et je
pense que c'est la base et puis
individualiser également les choses
toutes les solutions ne viennent pas de
mesure qui tombe sur toute une catégorie
de personnes ou une catégorie de
véhicules quand on entretient bien son
véhicule on doit pouvoir prouver qu'il
est bien entretenu qu'il ne pollue pas à
travers des contrôles techniques qui
existent déjà et qui pourraient
s'attacher aux questions de sécurité
comme elles le font aujourd'hui mais
également aux questions de pollution ces
zones affaiblissement les leur modalités
d'application varient selon les
territoires en nombre de jours il y en a
qui sont en 7 jours sur 7 d'autres
territoires qui exclus le week-end en
nombre d'heures aussi pareil il y en a
qui sont en 24 d'autres qui excluent
certaines heures est-ce que là-dessus la
différenciation a du bon est-ce que
c'est pas un peu compliqué du coup je me
suis beaucoup posé la question on prend
de la différenciation c'est là sur tous
les pratiquement vous le savez et là on
s'est dit est-ce que on peut respecter
si les 32 ZF supplémentaires se
rajouteront donc vous avez parlé on va
se retrouver avec 43 zones à faible
émission et notamment dans certaines
régions je pense à la région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes ou dans le dans les
Hauts-de-France également avec 6 aides à
fe les unes à côté des autres vous
imaginez pour les artisans qui vont
travailler dans dans ces ZF être obligé
de de changer de règle de demander des
dérogations différentes à chaque ZFE
c'est intenable donc il faut bien sûr
une harmonisation une coordination un
référentiel commun c'est pour ça qu'une
des recommandations c'est de pouvoir
permettre des conférences régionales
sous l'égide des préfets de région pour
faciliter l'harmonisation niveau
régional au niveau régional bien sûr pas
au niveau national parce que vous l'avez
justement dit
les territoires doivent être libres par
rapport à la concertation qui a été mise
en place par rapport aux habitudes de
leur concitoyens de monter au rythme
qu'elle souhaite et de mettre en place
les interdictions comme elles le
souhaitent et plus que les interdictions
un certain nombre de dérogations
également vous dénoncez dans ce rapport
un accompagnement défaillant de l'État
que manquait
moi je pense qu'il faut cibler les
choses les personnes qui sont en dehors
des ZF ont été oubliés elles ne peuvent
pas être aidées par les métropoles parce
qu'elles sont pas dans le périmètre et
c'est eux qui en ont le plus besoin et
c'est eux qu'on a un petit peu oublié
mais il y a eu Emmanuel Macron à lancer
des aides à l'achat de véhicules propres
pour vous c'est pas suffisant il faut
plus les cibler c'est ce que vous dites
il faut cibler il faut plus les cibler
il faut cibler les ménages modestes
également parce qu'il y a eu une aide
universelle qui partait d'un bon
sentiment mais on s'aperçoit que on
n'est pas tous égaux devant c'est ce
reste à financer notamment sur le
passage à l'électrique qui reste très
cher à la fois pour les particuliers je
ne vous parle même pas des transports de
marchandises et où la flotte aujourd'hui
est totalement à des carbonée avec une
technologie qui est balbutiante et avec
un coup qui est quelquefois de 4 à 5
fois supérieur au thermique
merci Oriane à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure on va parler Ukraine avec vous
au sujet ce sera à suivre dans le club
on va continuer à parler de ces sujets
transports parce que parmi les promesses
d'Emmanuel Macron pour une alternative à
la voiture il y a la création de RER
métropolitain dans une dizaine de villes
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté vendredi
un texte pour mettre en oeuvre cette
promesse reste la question du
financement qui est pas une petite
question qui doit payer
[Musique]
c'est d'avoir des réponses sur le
financier ce texte qui est arrivé à
l'assemblée qui a été votée et très bien
sur un certain nombre de choses et
notamment la montée en puissance de la
Société du Grand Paris qui va être amené
à changer de nom notamment si elle doit
s'occuper du RER métropolitain à
Marseille ce serait ce serait mieux mais
plus sérieusement je pense qu'il y a des
vrais compétences et que SNCF réseau a
besoin d'être aidé SNCF réseau entretien
déjà notre réseau qui est important mais
surtout les nouveaux projets et
notamment la douzaine de de nouveaux
projets qui vont se faire en région il
faut cette expertise il faut oui
il y a le projet de ligne nouvelle chez
nous qui va couvrir les nœuds
ferroviaires marseillais Toulonnais
niçois j'y suis très favorable j'ai très
fortement poussé ce dossier avec avec
les présidents de de région Christian
Estrosi et Renaud Muselier donc oui on
doit avancer sur sur ces sujets ce texte
va revenir chez nous mais il qu'on est
des engagements financiers de l'État
vous savez le
[Musique]
ferroviaire le transport en général et
le ferroviaire en particulier ne peut
pas se permettre d'avoir des des arrêts
sur certains projets c'est du long terme
il faut des finances pas en pérenne on
ne peut pas dire ah ben oui sous ce
quinquiète là on est favorable au projet
les successeurs ne sont plus favorables
au projet on arrête après ceux qui vont
venir ensuite disent on relance le
projet le temps est trop long dans les
transports et notamment dans le
ferroviaire il faut qu'on ait une
certaine continuité et il y a qu'une loi
de programmation qui peut permettre
d'avoir cette cette continuité sur le
transport et particulièrement sur le
ferroviaire sur le lion Turin forte il y
a eu des mobilisations ce weekend contre
ce projet qui date du début des années
90 mais la contestation et relancer
est-ce que vous la comprenez pas du tout
alors déjà que des écologistes ou ceux
qui se prétendent écologistes qui
étaient qui sont contre l'avion on avait
plutôt ils sont contre la route on avait
plutôt intégré par contre maintenant
contre le train et contre le fret
ferroviaire je ne comprends pas du tout
c'est un projet important ce sera un
projet qui va permettre de multiplier
fin d'arriver jusqu'à 50 % de de frais
de ferroviaire
existante et qu'elle n'est pas exploitée
et qu'il faudra d'abord exploiter à
plein cette ligne
171 la ligne existante voilà c'est un
projet en plus qui a été concerté
pendant des années vous l'avez rappelé
qui a été relancé c'est amusant par la
gauche pluriel en 2001 de Lionel Jospin
avec des écologistes au gouvernement
c'est un projet qui qui est aujourd'hui
réalisé à hauteur de 20% on a des
engagements internationaux avec l'Italie
on a des engagements européens il y a eu
des concertations il y a eu des des
études d'impact il y a eu des enquêtes
publiques il y a eu des déclarations
d'utilité publique tous ces faits dans
les règles dans notre pays on reproche
suffisamment à ces projets de prendre du
temps mais tout a été correctement fait
il ne faut pas l'arrêter c'est un non
sens on va aller justement voir
l'actualité du côté de chez vous à Nice
on retrouve Denis carreau Denis bonjour
merci d'être avec nous directeur des
rédactions du groupe Nice Matin Denis
avec vous on va parler d'un autre sujet
on parle du sur tourisme le gouvernement
veut s'attaquer à ce problème et
évidemment ça interroge dans votre
région
et oui le sur tourisme c'est un nouveau
mot et c'est un phénomène dont on parle
de plus en plus c'est le gouvernement a
présenté hier à Saint-Malo en Bretagne
un plan pour lutter contre le
surtourisme avec une série de mesures
alors qui consiste à la fois à
sensibiliser les touristes à utiliser
aussi des influenceurs pour faire passer
les messages mais aussi à mettre en
place à certains endroits des des quotas
des restrictions d'accès à des sites
touristiques alors c'est déjà le cas
dans certains endroits c'est le cas dans
notre région à côté de Marseille où le
l'accès aux calanques
du Sugiton et limité c'est le cas aussi
autour de la très belle île de
Porquerolles dans dans le Var des
mesures qui sont nécessaires à la fois
pour éviter une concentration trop
importante de touristes mais aussi et
surtout pour protéger ces sites ces
sites sensibles alors François de canson
le président de du comité région final
du tourisme de la région sud que vous
connaissez bien Philippe Tabarro il est
aussi François de canson président de la
fédération nationale ADN tourisme il est
globalement favorable à ce plan il
explique dans les colonnes de Nice-Matin
mais il a l'air sur les dangers du
tourisme bashing pour parler de tourisme
nous explique-t-il il faut des touristes
alors j'en viens à ma question Philippe
Tabarro on voit bien la difficulté à
concilier
économie et économie et économie
touristique est-ce qu'il faut en arriver
à limiter l'accès à certains lieux
touristiques comme le prévoit le
gouvernement écoutez vous l'avez
justement dit c'est un bon problème
pendant la période du covid qui a été
terrible pour tout le monde et notamment
pour l'industrie du tourisme si on nous
avait dit que quelques années après on
reviendrait à ce niveau de de tourisme
et de fréquentation et qu'on se poserait
la question de l'hyper fréquentation on
y aurait cru donc c'est plutôt bien je
trouve par contre que dans ce plan
gouvernemental on est sur un plan
uniquement de communication vous l'avez
dit de faire des réunions de travail
avec les influenceurs il y a un kit de
communication il y a des ambassadeurs du
tourisme qui vont se déployer sur la
France enfin voilà la concrètement il
faut des mesures il faut peut-être aider
les maires sur certains territoires très
particuliers à pouvoir utiliser leur
pouvoir de police qui peuvent être
accrus quand il y a des problèmes
d'environnement spécifique de protection
de cet environnement des questions de de
stationnement vous connaissez très bien
notre département il y a des problèmes
que les maires nous font remonter que ce
soit sur le village de Gourdon que ce
soit dans les gorges du Loup qui ont
connu ces difficultés l'été dernier donc
je pense que il faut donner aux maires
le pouvoir de réglementer les choses
il y a une proposition de loi dans cette
maison en 2019 du sénateur Bignon qui
était dans la navette parlementaire on
la navette n'est jamais revenue de
l'Assemblée je ne sais plus où elle se
trouve mais en tout cas ça c'est des
vrais sujets de donner les pouvoirs au
maire et arrêter avec ses gadgets de
d'influenceurs de qui tout
d'ambassadeurs
pour les avions il y a pas encore de ZF
mais de plus en plus de voix s'élèvent
pour deux pour demander à limiter les
trajets en avion c'est par exemple le
cas de l'ingénieur et expert de
l'environnement Jean-Marc jeancovici et
qui lui carrément préconise de limiter à
quatre vols par vie est-ce que il faut
en arriver là non je ne pense pas on en
a parlé le salon du Bourget va permettre
de d'échanger sur ces sujets il faut des
carbonner l'avion bien sûr il ne faut
pas non plus laisser faire tout et
n'importe quoi et je pense notamment à
un aéroport que vous connaissez bien qui
est celui de cane Mandelieu où il y a un
certain nombre de nuisances dans la
vallée de la sienne depuis des années
qui sont en train de de progresser ou
les élus et c'est de se mobiliser avec
la pour qui est plus d'atterrissage par
la mer au niveau nuisance après au
niveau environnemental il faut opérer
cette transition mais il ne faut pas
totalement et on a eu cette discussion
au moment de la proposition on doit de
Vincent apocanella la semaine dernière
sur les contrôleurs aériens il ne faut
pas que l'aérien soit le réceptacle de
toutes les difficultés qu'on a
environnementales ou de mobilité l'avion
peut avoir sa part peut régler un
certain nombre de situations on peut
prioriser le rail quand comme on l'a
fait dans climat est résilience mais
sincèrement ce serait totalement
inutile et très démagogique merci Denis
carro merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous la Une de Nice-Matin aujourd'hui
c'est baby blues c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Denis d'avoir été
avec nous évidemment à très vite dans
cette émission merci Philippe Tabarro
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi